This edition of Scoutmasters podcast is brought to you by the folks at Conahoe Creek Outfitters.
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get you great gear and great prizes for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at ConahoeCreekcom.
That's C-O-N-O-H-O-Creekcom.
And now the old scout master
Do have one question for you.
Tell me what a scout banana is?
Yes,
Well, you're going to need to listen to the entire podcast to get the answer to that question.
It's worth it, Trust me.
Hey, this is podcast number 175..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Heard from Greg Gotcher- and he said this in the post- why you should be a scouting volunteer.
You talked about not being sure if you're really suited to be a scouter.
That's exactly where I was when I decided to take on the position of Tiger Cub den leader.
I continued with boys through wolves and bears, and next year I'll be the Weeblows den leader.
Some were in there. I'm not sure when or where or how
I became a cub master as well.
Scouting kind of grows on you.
I love working with my son and with the other boys.
It's not too often that you really get to know your son's friends.
I love the fact that whenever I see the boys out and about, they know my name and they say: hi,
I've got the bug and I will be hooked for life. I can tell
I have another son coming up who will be a tiger the year after my oldest son moves on to Boy Scouts.
So I have a few years left doing this.
I'm looking forward to all of it and the fun and adventures that I have before me.
Why me? Why now? And why scouting? Well, why not
Jump right in? You won't regret a minute of it.
Greg, I couldn't agree more.
That's right. Jump right in, You won't regret a minute of it.
Owen Heyman is in Sheffield, England, and he got in touch with us via Facebook to say:
this is the most amazing resource for scouts online.
Thank you for your work. Thank you, Owen.
Good to hear from you, Glad that ScoutmasterCGcom translates into real English,
which is what is spoken over in the UK.
Scoutmaster Shane Strubart got in touch and he said:
I just wanted to thank you for taking the time to keep this awesome page and blog going.
It's by far the best resource for scouting I've come across
And furthermore, it's renewed my enthusiasm for scouting.
Well, thank you, Shane.
Things like that renew my enthusiasm for keeping up with the blog and the podcast,
But, honestly, always appreciative.
John Rust is with Cubpack 44 in Manchester, New Jersey,
And he wrote in to say
I want to thank you for having a first class, informative and professional site.
Scouting's purpose has always been to guide young boys as they grow and mature into men.
Before and after the recent membership policy vote, that mission is still intact.
One of the best qualities we as scouts can pass on is tolerance,
In my personal opinion, I think that the membership change will make it easier for us to do our job
of guiding boys into independent, self-sufficient, responsible men
who make decisions that will someday shape the world.
Thank you for keeping your page impartial.
Well, thank you, John.
I certainly do appreciate that.
I hasten to add that your particular opinion of my impartiality is not shared by all,
And several people have taken me to task for being impartial.
You know you do the best you can and you try to move forward,
And that's what we're all about.
So there's always plenty going on around here.
Make sure to check out the blog at ScoutmasterCGcom and see what we've been up to
Do. make sure to get over to the YouTube channel.
It's ScoutmasterCG on YouTube. this past week,
This past week, we posted a review of the Echo Zoom,
And the Echo Zoom is a wood stove.
It's particularly well suited to patrol camping.
It's a really great idea
And I want to make sure that you get in on it.
So go to YouTube, look for ScoutmasterCG
or just go to ScoutmasterCGcom
And you'll find that review with the video in a post from last week.
We just had our June scout circle last night
and the subject was the Order of the Arrow
And we were happy to welcome Andy Koh,
who is the Lodge Advisor for Octorero Lodge 22..
That's my OA Lodge.
Andy did a fantastic job of giving us an introduction
to the history of the Order of the Arrow
and the way the Order of the Arrow works
and the different things that are available to Scouts
who are members of the Order of the Arrow.
So you want to make sure to check that out.
It's the June scout circle at scoutsircleorg
and there'll be a link on how to find that presentation
and look at it in the post that contains this podcast.
Well, it's June and summer camps coming up
and hopefully we're all going to be very, very busy
and get ourselves into the outdoors.
And I've got a whole bunch of email, questions
and things like that that we've been saving up.
So don't be discouraged.
We're going to get to those in a future podcast.
But this week it's time for another installment
of the Colorado experiment.
Those of you that have been following along
will recall that we're tracking the progress
of a brand new troop out in Colorado.
We got Arlam Ward, the brand new scout master
of that brand new troop, to give us an update
And that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
And now our next episode of the Colorado experiment.
Well, I'm happy to welcome Arlam Ward
back to the Scout Master Podcast.
We're checking up on troop 17 out there in Colorado.
It's a brand new troop
And I think, Arlam, this is our third installment, right?
Yes,
Just to catch everybody up.
Previously on the Colorado experiment,
Right? previously on the Colorado experiment,
That's what I was looking for.
So previously on the Colorado experiment,
we kind of tracked the whole idea of starting a troop.
Let's just go back there real quick
in case somebody hasn't heard the whole story.
You decided to go ahead and start a scout troop.
You had been a cub master
And you found that there were any number of boys
in your locality who had one time been in scouts
who decided that the idea of a new troop was appealing to them
and they decided to come back in.
It was originally started as a conversation
between families that had weeblos
and we were starting to look around at troops
and the conversations were:
well, we can do this or we can do this,
or we can start one.
Yeah, don't have those conversations, folks,
You're going to be right,
Otherwise you'll be on the podcast as an experiment.
That's where it started.
And then, talking to the charter partner,
it was: well, there's a number of boys
that have dropped out of scouting. that like to.
The part that really resonated with me
is that they like to go camping,
They like to do the outdoor stuff,
but they dropped out of scouting
And that was just kind of well. okay,
that seems to me that there's a different approach
that we can take to the scouting
that will keep those boys involved.
The last time we spoke
you were still waiting on having, like, a meeting place.
Have you got a meeting place, yet
Temporarily we have one.
There's a church in our neighborhood
that makes their facility available,
So we have set up through the summer
to work with this church
before we move over to our permanent home.
I believe the last time we talked
you had been out on a hike
but you were looking forward to your first camping trip.
Tell us a little bit about how that came about
and how it went.
Okay, when we sat down originally
with the very initial parts of the PLC
and said, okay, let's start naming activities
that we want to do on a monthly basis,
We want to do something this month
but we don't have time to really put much together,
So let's go hiking.
Then we set a date for the first camping trip,
which was over Memorial Day weekend.
So we weren't really planning on doing a summer camp.
but the boys came back and said:
you know, we would like to go to summer camp.
So we found a summer camp to go to
and set that up for July.
And then in August
we have camping trips specific to the PLC,
doing annual planning and leadership training
and stuff like that,
Then kicking off the school year
with a trained PLC
and probably a court of honor and stuff like that.
And then after that
it all depends on what they do in August.
And so how did this camping trip go
that you did on Memorial Day weekend?
Nothing ever goes quite as planned,
Get out,
Really.
So the week that we were supposed to go camping,
I get a call from the camp post
in the National Forest where we were going.
He called me.
He's like: yeah,
you have a reservation for this coming weekend.
There's still two feet of snow in your campsite.
So we told him we'd find something else
And we moved the campsite.
but it turns out the place we were at was fantastic.
As the adults
we didn't really set much in the way of agenda.
The boys,
when they had set up this initial camping trip,
said: let's do something where we all get together
and get to know each other.
He goes because we don't all really know each other at this point.
And there was about 10 scouts that went on. this trip
Had a lot of parents.
I was really surprised at the number of parents that went
And I think they were just kind of curious to see how this was going to go.
So we had almost as many parents as we had scouts.
The scouts were separated from each other.
The two patrols were separated from each other by about 100 yards
And they were separated from us by about 100 or 150 yards as well.
And I kept all the parents up with me
And when we had talked beforehand
I said: bring a chair- preferably a good book-
and stay out of their campsites.
It was where we started that conversation
And it worked out really well,
A lot better than I expected.
We had two new patrol leaders,
One's 12 and one's 13..
They'd never been patrol leaders before.
They were very excited about it.
They set up their own campsites.
We kind of gave them an area and you know
beforehand had mentioned to them.
perhaps you want to read through your book where it says how to pick a campsite,
because you're going to be picking one.
One patrol brought a gigantic eight-person tent
and put everybody in one tent,
which was interesting.
I'm not sure they'll do that again.
It was an experiment.
They did their own cooking,
They did their own breakfast.
We got together for dinners,
But it was a good chance for us to sit around and eat together
and talk and things like that.
Most of my weekend was checking in everyone somewhere with the patrol leaders
and seeing what they were up to.
We figured, since we were coming up with Dutch ovens and cars
and things like that,
it was a good time to go through all the ax yard stuff,
since you don't want to take those on a backpacking trip.
The patrols would rotate through
and they'd talk to one of the adults over at the ax yard
who was teaching them about what an ax yard was
and how it works,
and somebody else went through how to sharpen an ax.
For the rest of the weekend
they chopped wood for fun,
which it was completely unexpected on my part.
The adults were laughing.
If we had sat down and said:
here's a half of a pickup truck full of wood.
your job for the rest of the weekend
is to split it into smaller pieces
and burn it all up before we go home.
It would have been complaints and drudgery and things like that.
But since it was their idea that they want-
hey, we want to have another fire,
Can we chop more wood?
For the most part it was all kind of their direction.
The patrol leader stepped up and did a fantastic job,
better than I had ever hoped.
One patrol was up before the adults.
They had cooked their breakfast
and had cleaned everything up
and were ready to go fishing
before the adults were even done with their breakfast.
They're definitely motivated.
It resonates with them
The whole working as a patrol thing.
We did the start, stop and continue stuff
as a whole group during dinner the last night
And then I also met with the patrol leaders separately.
The senior patrol leaders didn't show up,
both being in high school
and it being the weekend, right after school got out.
They were otherwise engaged,
So it was really the two patrol leaders.
It was very eye-opening for them
and very eye-opening for me as well.
I had a patrol leader that said
I had a hard time this weekend getting people
to do the jobs that they were assigned to do.
When I was meeting with the two patrol leaders
we kind of talked about that for a little bit.
I said: well, a lot of times
it's one of those things where,
as a patrol leader and the older guys,
you guys want to do the fun stuff,
So you assign each other to do the fun parts,
the cooking parts,
and then leave the younger, less experienced guys
to do the cleanup.
I said it's much more effective, first of all,
to put an experienced guy with a young guy
so that you at least have somebody involved
that knows what's going on.
Another thing is to write it out as a duty roster.
I had mentioned it beforehand,
but they didn't do it,
And so we talked about it afterwards and said,
well, this is one of the reasons, so that everybody can see
that the load is being shared around,
that it's not favoritism,
You're not picking on anybody.
But here, written in black and white,
is: the duty is to get us through the weekend as a patrol,
and that that's really useful.
And he took it to heart.
The other patrol leader had a suggestion as well.
He goes: well, what we did was we had specific people cook,
but then everybody was responsible for cleaning up.
It's those little challenges along the way
and the discussions that we have
as the patrol leaders counsel.
that kind of moves them towards more proficiency.
You made a suggestion.
You kind of pointed out: okay,
this might be a good idea, fellas,
And both the patrols basically ignored you,
Not out of any ill will or anything like that.
They just, yeah, well, Mr Ward,
that's a great idea.
Thanks,
They were focused on other things. yes,
Yes, they got to experiment
and they discovered that, jeez,
the old man might know something.
We might actually give that a try
To me that kind of defines the scout approach.
Instead of castigating them and saying, jeez,
well, you know, if you've just done what I told you,
you kind of go now. do you see the reason behind this?
Do you get the idea that this might be a good idea?
It sounds like you may have won one convert
and one had a way of just doing it by himself.
Yeah, which work this time, may not work next time,
or it may work forever,
and then he never actually uses a duty roster.
you know, that's fine with me as long as it
patrol functions. but when it comes to me later
and says: you know, I still can't get everybody
to do their jobs, I suppose
we'll talk about it again.
That's the heart of letting boys discover
what they need to discover.
You've cultivated a bit of a tolerance
for the adversity and uncertainty
that that type of thing causes.
Did you get any kind of resistance
from the other adults involved,
maybe being less tolerant about that idea?
Oh, absolutely.
Actually, on that very same topic,
I was talking to one of the
assistant scout masters and he said
I had noticed that they didn't do a duty roster
and I was going to go tell them they had to
and we talked and said, no, it's better this way,
that they tried their method.
they didn't seem to work quite as well,
so it bears a lot more weight. you know,
when they can align it with their own experience
rather than great. here comes Mr Ward.
he's got all these forms I have to fill out
for no reason, when really all we want to do
is go to the X-Arch and chop wood.
it's so much better when it comes back from them.
you know, sometimes they spend an
inordinate amount of time actually cleaning
after a meal,
which I understand isn't
Not unusual-
Yeah, it's not unique to my troop,
but they got better at it as the weekend went on.
but I had one patrol the first
day that I think breakfast
kind of spilled over into lunch
but nobody was leaving the adult area
and running down there to see what the problem was.
No, no, there was concerns.
you know, parents going,
what are the patrols doing?
and they said, well, you know this one's doing this one,
this one's, you know, finishing up breakfast
and they're like: still, it's 10.30, it's 11 o'clock.
it's like, well, yes,
but they're working out.
you know best way to clean their stuff.
and I talked to a number of adults
over the weekend, you know,
especially having a lot of the parents there,
I think they saw the benefit.
a number of them came up to me
as the weekend went on and said
I understand a lot more about scouting now
than I did before this weekend started.
you know it's like you put them down there
and they have to figure it out on their own.
you know like it was,
like it was my idea,
Brilliant, it was absolutely brilliant.
Yeah, it was like.
yeah, well, that's true.
you know we need to keep an eye out
for certain things,
like the safety things,
and you know the overwhelming frustration
that you know can set in after a while.
you know where you give them
a bit of direction to go along with that,
but for the most part you leave it to them
to settle it out themselves.
there's a couple of times I had to
kind of follow a parent that I saw
wandering off towards the patrol areas
and I'd follow, kind of follow them down there
and I'd say, you know they'd get down there
and they'd ask the boys how things were going
and then when they'd start reaching for stuff,
come back with me, let's go this way,
and they'd look at me like they got caught,
and they'd kind of hit me in the head
and come back up
and come back up, but in talking to some of the
scouts afterwards, I didn't
catch as much of that as I think
I probably should have.
for the most part, though, you know, let them
figure things out.
it's not like we kept them segregated all weekend long.
when the patrol says, hey, I want to go fishing,
well, you know the dad's from that patrol-
most of them went with them.
they should be able to kind of suss this out a little bit,
and they should be able to turn to the adults
and say: thank you very much,
but we're good,
go away now, leave us alone.
that's a hard thing
for boys to be able to do, though,
you know. I think a lot of that comes
from something that
doesn't get stressed enough.
you know, praise them for the littlest things,
and I know that you've talked about this before,
and you know, in trainings and things like that,
it doesn't come up nearly as often as it should,
which is
when they do the littlest things right.
keep on the praise,
reframe the failures,
as we could do this better.
we- you know, not you,
but we could do this better,
even just in the course of a weekend
you see the difference in their confidence.
so you talk to them about: hey, you know
you guys are doing great, but there's a couple of things we could improve.
when we did the stop, start and continue,
it was the same thing. you know,
you guys had a great weekend, we had a lot of fun.
but let's just kind of take a minute to review.
so you're talking about a process
called stop, start and continue.
just tell me what the basics
of that process are.
it's a review tool. you know. stop,
it's the things that you're going to stop doing,
things that didn't work out for us,
things that cause problems for us.
these are the things that we're going to stop doing.
but you don't run down there and say stop,
stop, don't do that.
this is reflective.
yeah, this is a reflection tool. for sure.
it's definitely better if these things come from the scouts
than if they come from the adults.
I was kind of leading them through the process.
the adults were quiet the whole time.
these conversations came from the scouts,
which was a bit surprising,
but of course, at this point
they had been through two days and we tell them-
and believe the boys alone-
maybe they were listening to them,
chasing them down, throwing a lasso around.
yeah
right, gentle, redirection.
so there's the things we're going to stop doing,
the things that we should continue doing,
and I think that's great that it ends with the continue stuff.
when we started that conversation,
you know I said this is a review tool.
what sort of things have come up
over the weekend that were issues?
and then a patrol leader raised his hand,
he goes. you know, we need to work harder
at including everybody.
that was kind of open the floodgate
to that point. so you know we should work harder
at helping people
feel included, that even if,
as we go along, you guys are going to be,
you know, tighten it as a patrol,
but there's going to be outsiders
of visitors that are going to be joining you
and you're going to have to spend some time
making sure that they're included
and keep that in mind as you're going along.
and that just led into a whole bunch of other things
that they discussed
as far as things that we should start doing
or stop doing.
so this isn't your opportunity as the scout master
to lay down a lecture.
this is your opportunity to listen
to what the boys are saying
a little bit. is that kind of the spirit of it-
Yeah,
you know one to
direct it kind of. in general,
there's going to be a few silly answers,
but you want to direct it.
what really went on this weekend,
because it wasn't all rainbows and sunshine.
there's going to be conflicts.
there has to be. otherwise
it's not
their reason for going out on these camping trips,
but my reason for taking them out there
is to put some challenging situations in front of them-
and they're not always going to have the right answers-
and to discuss that
as a group
and it means so much more coming from them
than it does coming from me.
but it allows
in that environment
for the scout master, whoever is leading it to
you're facilitating a discussion
more than laying down the law.
any time in the course of the last couple of months
that I felt like I needed to just say
this is the way it's going to be.
I've had to pause and say
it's not necessary that I lay down the law
and do that.
there's going to be struggles on their part
if we remove all of that and it just becomes
we're going to do things the way that this
task master or scout master, ward wants to do it.
it's not going to be any fun for anybody
and they're going to miss out
on the chances to struggle with
the weekend. you describe:
you go, you go camping, you set up the patrol sites,
the guys cook,
they take whatever time they're going to need to do that.
they maybe take a hike
fishing.
there was a little structured activity
around doing a tote and chip
and an axe yard and stuff like that.
it doesn't sound like you were
particularly driven
on trying to get requirements done
or anything like that.
we mentioned it to the patrol leaders that they should go through the books
and they took it to heart.
you can look down and see them all gathered around the picnic table.
they all had their books out
and they were going through stuff.
there were a few things that I pointed out specifically
in the course of making dinner.
we were talking about the raw chicken
and handling that
and controlling who touches that and what touches that.
why do you think that is?
and I looked in and said you know that's one of the
requirements for first class
is to discuss that and other things around food safety
and it was like a light bulb.
it was like really it was
in passing more than it was
now. we're going to sit down
and we're going to work out all the food safety stuff
for first class.
they do this stuff if they go camping
and they do exactly what you described.
they're just doing that stuff. anyway,
you've had the first camping trip.
you went home with happy scouts.
you went home having
begun to establish
the adult role in this new troop
as how the adults were going to relate
to the scouts
and where the boundary lines were going to be.
and now you're going to be off to summer camp
in july.
is that the next big event for you guys?
between there, in june we have
a backpacking trip.
so you're going to go backpacking
and just as a result of having done that,
some advancement is going to happen
for them. it's a load of fun
for us. it improves that skill set
for them to go on the backpacking trip.
the program is not being driven
by getting stuff done.
the program is being driven by
what the scouts want to do.
that's, I think, a really important
distinction. you're not going backpacking
because you want everybody to get backpacking
merit badge.
this is the slate of activities that they wanted to do.
I think that's a
terrifically important piece
that sometimes just doesn't get
into the mind
of an adult leader.
I think that, as we're observing your experiment,
it's going to be interesting
to see how that pans out.
yeah, it was
actually. I think this was one that was
kind of on the schedule from the very beginning.
I don't know if this is going to
take off or not, but I said, you know, this would be a fantastic
opportunity to learn some map and compass skills,
some more entering,
and just mentioned that and they're like, oh yeah, that would be great
ways you to do it while you're
out there than it is for them to talk through,
walk it through them
in a classroom setting
at a meeting. so
I think we're pretty well caught up
on the progress of the experiment so far.
I do have one question for you:
tell me what a scout banana
is.
yes,
the last PLC meeting.
these are getting much more interesting
now that we have
a variety of scouts involved in the PLC.
you've got the patrol leaders and the senior
patrol leaders and. but what happened
was we were talking about troop t-shirts.
this was more of a conversation between
them and I was kind of out of it
at this point. I was writing some other things down
and just kind of listening to what was going on.
one of them said, you know, we should do it like
football jerseys, we should put troop 17
across the shoulder, across the back.
and one of those guys said, yeah, that's a great idea.
and something else says, well, what do we put on the front?
and the scout says,
well, you know, maybe we put
troop 17 and maybe
Thornton Colorado on it and the scout banana.
and like everybody was confused
and the what
he looks around, kind of
exactly, you know, the scout banana, it's on everything.
I'm just listening to this going.
what is he talking about?
and then it occurred to me that he was talking about the
Florida League, the scout banana,
and from that I can't look at the thing now
without seeing this banana shape
in the middle.
it was,
it was hilarious.
I took all of myself control
to keep from busting out laughing.
when a few more rounds
of discussion, you know,
because you know, like in the middle of the scout badge,
and they're like you mean this thing? and one of them goes:
isn't that a fedora? and somebody else knows that's,
that's a hat, you know,
you know. and finally I told them:
you know, this is, it's a Florida League
gonna be the scout banana, at least in this troop,
and I think it's
a fantastic idea to have it on the front
of the t-shirt. so, yes, yes, why
wouldn't you want to call it the scout banana
from now on?
I have a friend of mine that's a graphic
artist and I sent her
the image of the
world scout emblem, the Florida League
in the center, and I said: can you take that
in the middle
and kind of turn it into a similar
shape, but something that
looks like a peel of banana?
see if we can get that into the t-shirts. but yeah,
I was. that was a fantastic
PLC meeting for me. I had
a 12 year old
patrol leader that got everybody's
attention at the meeting and said, okay,
you know, kind of shyly, and looking down
the table, says you know, I've been reading my patrol
leader's book, which in itself
kind of raised my eyebrows, like really,
that's fantastic.
he goes
and in there it says
it's good to have goals and it's like,
well, great. so not only is he reading this,
but he's understanding it and he's
taking it to heart.
again. I couldn't have
signed this book and made him read it
and had this kind of an effect.
but he goes. so let's set a goal
of everybody advancing
two ranks and then have like
a troop meeting. that's all
like games and food.
I just kind of looked at the patrol leader at that point,
you know, because he wasn't talking to me,
he was talking to the PLC, you know,
and I looked over the patrol leader and was like, okay,
just don't
mess this up is what I was thinking,
you know. it's like
just encourage this as much
as you can and just kind of made eye contact
with him about, you know,
with an approving look, as best as I could,
without you know, actually saying anything.
and he took it and ran with it
and said, oh, that's a great idea. you know,
I think we should certainly do that.
and at the
next troop meeting, at the closing circle,
that same patrol leader announced it
to the entire troop and said: this is what we're going to do
going forward. you know,
and you know it's been
fantastic. I, you know
I didn't dream
that it would work as well as it does.
the key to making
that work is the attitude of
the scout master, if you're willing,
like I said, to have that kind of
tolerance for uncertainty
and a little bit of adversity
and you're comfortable with letting them sit there
and discuss without interjecting
and without carrying on a whole lot.
they're going to catch on and I think once
they catch on you have a momentum
that it would take concerted effort
to stop. it is remarkable
that all of this crazy stuff
actually does work.
you know, I said that back
in Cub Scouts too. it's like wow,
these things that they've
talked about and they've done for
100 years, they
actually work.
the mindset of boys isn't that different today
than it was when they kicked off
scouting in the first place.
you give them a pile of wood
in an axe and teach them how
to swing an axe safely.
they'll spend all day chopping it into
little pieces for no other reason
than
it's fun and a little bit dangerous.
it really resonates with them.
we're out here, we're doing stuff,
we're making a real difference because I can chop up this wood
and I can take it over there
and we can build a fire with it.
they loved it. they were given enough freedom
to kind of be masters
of their own destiny without having someone
come in and say:
that's not how you make pancakes and eggs in the morning.
free them up to do their thing
and then you say: these are the things that we have to meet
and you keep that as limited
as possible
rather than laying down the law all weekend long.
we laid down the law before we left.
we're not leaving a messy campsite
and you're not putting away cook gear
that has food on it. still,
it sounds like things are going swimmingly.
you've got some happy scouts,
you've got some slightly skeptical
adults, but you seem to be managing.
I'm going to be interested to talk to you
after you guys are back from summer camp.
well, thanks,
it's been a great ride
that we get to document it
and share it this way.
I certainly appreciate the encouragement along the way
and I've learned a lot from the podcast
and hopefully this will
help somebody else out there
that's either in a similar situation,
thinking about being in a similar situation,
or wants to revamp something that they've already got going on.
it only takes one jump
to get into the volcano.
it does. it's a really small step.
surprisingly,
there's a fair bit of research that went into this.
I've read a ton of stuff
on the way
scouting in theory
is supposed to work.
it's still surprising how well it works.
just offering it to the boys
and saying: this is yours, go with it.
thanks again, Arlen,
you bet
well. thanks so much
for listening to this edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can also subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes
and when you do,
if you have a chance,
leave a comment or review or a rating.
you can also access the podcast
on your mobile device through
Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right. you can follow us at scoutmasterblog
on Facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive scoutmastercg circle,
search for scoutmastercg
on google plus.
remember, you can email me if all else fails.
zoom into the late 90's
and send your comments, questions
and wild ideas to
Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
nope, it's just me
talking into a microphone
and trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders
and hopefully having a little bit of fun along the way.
speaking of fun, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and group camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
until next time.
Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe
and like the video.
See you next time.
Bye.